all right now to the war in Ukraine this
morning the country's government
repeated an urgent call for Western
allies to send Modern tanks to help
fight the Russians and as U.S and NATO
officials discussed the request
ukrainians continue to fight and die on
the front lines and that's where we find
Deborah patta alongside soldiers who are
battling the Invaders and the weather
along freezing mighty muddy roads were
taken to an undisclosed location on the
front line not far from the Russian
border to meet the men of the begun
Special Forces Brigade look up and you
see a typical Ukrainian Pine Forest but
down below cut into the iron hard Earth
is a Warren of fortifications
it's one thing to take back territory
but Ukraine also has to defend it which
is why they are trenches along hundreds
of miles of the front line where
soldiers are battling the elements mud
rain extreme cold
Ukrainian forces are bracing themselves
for the coldest weeks of winter it's
very warm in here underground a wood
fire keeps the main from freezing there
are warm beds hot food and drinks
it's not so hard you can get used to any
harsh conditions major chicken told us
what you don't get used to he said are
the deaths of civilians
the commander and his men have been
involved in some of the bloodiest
fighting in the country's East where
Ukrainian soldiers are digging in across
swathes of ground to defend against
Russian counter-offensives you're
building a whole lot of news
you building is it difficult to build
trenches when the ground is Frozen
it's very difficult he said it's rock
solid ice with constant rain and snow
you can build all the trenches you want
chicken told us but more heavy weapons
is the quickest way to win the war
against Russia
and that's why the U.S decision to send
fighting vehicles and missile defense
systems has been welcomed here on the
battlefield Tony
Deborah pataforce in Ukraine on the
front lines Deborah thank you very much